This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. In the popular imagination, leaders are visionaries. They're single-minded. Like Morpheus, in the Matrix films, they know exactly how to rally the troops when catastrophe looms. Tonight, let us make them remember. This is Zion, and we are not afraid! Or take the Wolf of Wall Street in which Leonardo DiCaprio plays a ruthless stock trader.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在大众的想象中，领导者都是有远见的人。他们目标单一。就像《黑客帝国》里的墨菲斯一样，当灾难降临时，他们非常清楚如何振奋人心。今晚，让我们让他们记住。这里是锡安，我们无所畏惧！或者以《华尔街之狼》为例，莱昂纳多·迪卡普里奥在片中饰演一名冷酷无情的股票交易员。
At one point, he gives a motivational speech to his sales team. Are you behind on your credit card bills? God, pick up the phone and start dialing. Is it Lamor ready to evict you? Good! Pick up the phone and start dialing. Is the landlord ready to evict you? Good, pick up the phone and start dialing. I want you to deal with your problems by becoming rich. Yeah! In Hollywood's imagination, leaders often have
在某个场景中，他向销售团队发表了一场励志演讲。你的信用卡账单逾期了吗？天哪，拿起电话开始拨号吧。拉莫尔准备把你赶出去吗？很好！拿起电话开始拨号。房东准备把你赶出去吗？很好，拿起电话开始拨号。我希望你们通过变得富有来解决问题。耶！在好莱坞的想象中，领导者往往具有
messianic vision and unshakeable conviction. I can't accomplish a god damn thing of any human meaning or worth until we cure ourselves of slavery and end this presidential war. Especially in the United States, we celebrate certainty and look down on those who express doubt, caution caution and hesitation. This week on Hidden Brain, we examine the psychological origins and the unforeseen consequences of certainty. And we'll explore the magic that happens when we replace certitude with curiosity.
弥赛亚般的远见和动摇不得的信念。除非我们治愈奴役的弊病并结束这场总统战争，否则我干不出任何具有人类意义或价值的宏伟大业。尤其在美国，我们崇尚确定性，看不起那些表达怀疑、谨慎和犹豫的人。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们将探讨确定性的心理根源及其意料之外的后果。我们还将探索用好奇心取代确凿信念时所发生的奇迹。
Adam Grant is an organizational psychologist at the Wharton School. He is the author of Think Again, the power of knowing what you don't know. He is interested in the question of obstinacy. Why do so many of us find it difficult to question our own beliefs and challenge our own views? Adam Grant, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shankar, such a treat to be back here. On the face of it, if I had known you as a kid, I might not have predicted that you would grow up
亚当·格兰特是沃顿商学院的组织心理学家。他是《再次思考：知道你所不知道的力量》一书的作者。他对执拗这一问题很感兴趣。为什么我们当中有这么多人觉得很难性质去质疑自己的信念和挑战自己的观点？亚当·格兰特，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔，很高兴能再次来到这里。表面上看，如果我从小就认识你，我可能不会预测到你长大后
to write a book about the virtues of humility. As a kid, you say you earned the nickname Mr. Facts. You were very knowledgeable, but it sounds like you, yourself, had trouble admitting that you were ever wrong. I think I was a pretty annoying kid. It must have been really unpleasant for my friends too, because I spent so many hours trading baseball cards. And I'd say, well, this Mark McGuire rookie
会写一本关于谦逊美德的书。你说自己小时候赢得过“事实先生”的外号。你知识渊博，但听起来，你自己似乎很难承认自己有过错误。我想我小时候是个挺讨人嫌的孩子。我的朋友们一定也觉得很不愉快，因为我花了太多时间交易棒球卡。我会说，嗯，这张马克·麦奎尔的新秀卡
is not worth what you think it is, because he only had a 282 batting average in 1989, and I just rattle off these random statistics. And I think most of the time, my friends could care less. And over a couple of years, I learned the hard way that this was not serving me well if I cared about people enjoying interacting with me. And also, if I cared about my own learning,
并不像你想象的那么值钱，因为他在1989年的击球率只有0.282，然后我就滔滔不绝地背诵这些随机的统计数据。而且我认为大多数时候，我的朋友们根本不在乎。几年后，我用惨痛的教训认识到，如果我在乎别人是否喜欢与我互动，这种做法对我是没有帮助的。而且，如果我在乎自己的学习，
the moment that comes to mind is, I must have been in seventh grade. I think I was 12. My friend Khan was on the phone with me. It was a commercial during a sign-feld. And we got into an argument. I don't remember what it was about. And I just refused to give in, even though he had really good proof. And eventually he hung up on me. And I called him back. And I said said to the power go out, why did the line drop? And he said, I won't talk to you until you admit you're wrong. Yeah. And we had a habit of talking every day. So it was a it was a big moment. And by that
浮现在我脑海中的那个时刻，我当时一定在上七年级。我想我12岁。我的朋友汗正在和我打电话。那是《宋飞传》播放期间的一个广告。我们争吵了起来。我不记得是为了什么。我就是拒绝妥协，尽管他有很好的证据。最后他挂了我的电话。我又给他打了过去。我对他说，是电力中断了吗，为什么电话断了？他说，除非你承认自己错了，否则我不会跟你说话。是的。我们过去习惯每天都聊天。所以这是一个非常重要的时刻。到那个
point, it was clear that he was right. But I was still having a hard time admitting it. And that bothered me. Adam I was still having a hard time admitting it and that bothered me. Adam no longer has a big problem when it comes to admitting he's wrong but he does still suffer from a related problem. He finds it hard to challenge other people when they do or say something wrong. Well I think some of this stems from my personality. I'm a pretty agreeable person. So agreeableness is one of the major dimensions of personality around the world. We think of agreeable people as warm, friendly, polite, welcoming, Canadian.
时候，很明显他是对的。但我还是很难承认这一点。这让我很烦恼。亚当，我还是很难承认这一点，这让我很烦恼。亚当在承认错误方面已经没有什么大问题了，但他仍然受一个相关问题困扰。当别人做了或说了错误的事情时，他发现很难去挑战他们。嗯，我想这部分源于我的性格。我是一个随和的人。所以随和是世界各地性格的主要维度之一。我们认为随和的人热情、友好、礼貌、热情、很有加拿大风范。
Disagreeable people tend to be more critical, skeptical, and challenging. And they're also statistically overrepresented among engineers and lawyers. And as long as I can remember, I've been agreeable. And it's weird because on the one hand, I hated admitting I was wrong and I was extremely stubborn. But on the other hand, I really liked harmony. And I wanted to get along with other people. And I can think of multiple situations where I've been sitting in a new bird or a lift and the air conditioning is just blasting.
不随和的人往往更具批判性、怀疑性和挑战性。在统计学上，他们在工程师和律师中也占据了过高的比例。而且从我记事起，我一直是个随和的人。这很奇怪，因为一方面，我讨厌承认自己错误，而且我极其顽固。但另一方面，我真的很喜欢和谐。我想和别人相处融洽。我能想到好几种情况，当时我正坐在优步或利夫特车上，空调开得极大。
And it's just too uncomfortable to ask the driver to turn it down because it's not my car. And so I'll just sit there with my teeth chattering until the ride is over. And being agreeable seems like a good thing, but you also point out in the book that it can come with a downside. Yeah, I think like everything else in life, it has trade-offs. So on the one hand, agreeable people create a lot of harmony. They tend to get along with other people. They're constantly encouraging.
而且冷得太难受了，以至于我不好意思让司机把空调调小，因为这不是我的车。所以我只能坐在那里直打哆嗦，直到车程结束。随和似乎是一件好事，但你在书中也指出，它也有不好的一面。是的，我想和生活中的其他事情一样，它也有权衡取舍。一方面，随和的人创造了很多和谐。他们往往能和别人相处得很好。他们不断地鼓励他人。
But if you look at the data on leadership effectiveness, one of the things you see is highly agreeable people tend to be worse at leading organizations and teams than people who are somewhere in the middle of that spectrum. And the risk is that sometimes they're too nice, they're too polite, they say yes to everything, and they don't challenge people enough. And I've felt that. We see that in negotiations too, where agreeable people are really prone to what's called agreement bias, cleverly, where you come to the table, somebody offers you a terrible deal, but you hate the idea of saying no. And so you say yes to something
但如果你看看关于领导效能的数据，你会发现的一个现象是，高度随和的人在领导组织和团队方面，往往比处于该光谱中间的人表现得更差。风险在于，有时候他们太好、太礼貌，对什么都说好，而且对别人的挑战不够。我深有体会。我们在谈判中也能看到这一点，随和的人非常容易陷入所谓的“一致性偏误”——巧妙的是，当你来到谈判桌前，有人给你开出一个糟糕的交易，但你又讨厌拒绝这个想法。于是你对某些
that's not in your best interest. Being agreeable and wanting to be seen as agreeable are only two of the drivers behind our reluctance to second-guess ourselves and second-guess others. Another source of the problem has to do with a popular notion about the risks of changing once-mind. If you're a student who takes multiple choice tests, or if you've watched TV quiz shows like who wants to be a millionaire, where you're given four possible answers to each question and have to pick the right one, you have likely experienced the first instinct fallacy. It's one of the most interesting findings in the psychology of being a student.
不符合你最佳利益的事情说好。随和以及渴望被视为随和，只是我们不愿反思自己和反思他人的两个驱动因素。问题的另一个根源与一种关于改变初衷之风险的流行观念有关。如果你是一个参加选择题考试的学生，或者你看过像《谁想成为百万富翁》这样的电视问答节目，在节目中，每个问题都会给你四个可能的答案，你必须从中挑选出正确的答案，那么你很可能是经历过第一直觉谬误。这是学生心理学中最有趣的发现之一。
It takes back to an experience we all had growing up. I remember my mom telling me, if you're unsure of an answer on a test, go with your gut. Go with your first instinct. And yet, if you look at the research, if you do go with your gut versus you second guess your first instinct, which is better. And on average, the vast majority of students who reject their gut, they actually improve their scores on average. And so there's a fallacy that your first thoughts are your best thoughts.
这可以追溯到我们成长过程中都有过的一次经历。我记得我妈妈对我说，如果你对考试中的某个答案不确定，那就凭直觉走。相信你的第一直觉。然而，如果你看看研究，如果你坚持直觉，与重新审视你的第一直觉相比，哪个更好。平均而言，绝大多数拒绝直觉的学生，他们的平均分数实际上有所提高。因此，存在一种谬误，即你的第一想法就是最好的想法。
A lot of times intuition is just subconscious pattern recognition and the patterns that you're recognizing from the past may not be relevant to the problem you're solving right now in the present. And so you don't want to trust your gut, you want to test your gut. And even when you tell people about this evidence, they are still reluctant to rethink their first answer. I wonder if some of this has to do with the role of regret. If I have a first instinct, a first answer, and I'm wrong about it, I'm going to experience some regret. But if I come up with an answer, and then I switch to the wrong answer
很多时候，直觉只是潜意识中的模式识别，你从过去识别出的模式可能与你现在正在解决的问题无关。所以，你不要盲目相信直觉，而是要检验直觉。甚至当你向人们讲述这些证据时，他们仍然不愿意重新考虑他们的第一个答案。我在想，这其中是否有一部分与遗憾的作用有关。如果我有一个最初的直觉，一个最初的答案，而且我弄错了，我会感到有些遗憾。但如果我想出了一个答案，然后我换成了错误的答案，
and it turned out my first answer was actually correct, presumably I would experience greater regret now because I had the sense I actually had the right answer and I foolishly went and changed my mind. That is such an eloquent summary of what a number of psychologists have argued and found. That the regret, the pain of having had the right answer and then undone it is much greater than the pain of sticking with what you thought was the right answer, even though it was wrong. So stubbornness and obstinacy and the first instincting fallacy affect not just our personal lives, but they also affect things on a much bigger scale. Can you tell me the story of the meteoric rise and fall of Blackberry, Adam?
结果证明我的第一个答案其实是正确的，据推测，我现在会感到更大的遗憾，因为我有种感觉，我实际上掌握了正确的答案，而我却愚蠢地去改变了主意。这是对许多心理学家所争论和发现的结论的一个非常精彩的总结。那就是，曾经拥有正确答案却又将其否定所带来的遗憾和痛苦，要远大于坚持你认为是正确答案（尽管它是错的）所带来的痛苦。因此，顽固、执拗和第一直觉谬误不仅影响我们的个人生活，也以更大的规模影响着事情。亚当，你能给我讲讲黑莓手机迅速崛起又衰落的故事吗？
Sure. The beloved Blackberry. I still miss my Blackberry. The keyboard in particular, I wish the iPhone had that. You too? Yes, me too. I'm so glad I'm not alone. Maybe one day.
当然。备受喜爱的黑莓。我仍然怀念我的黑莓。尤其是键盘，我希望iPhone也能有那样的设计。你也是？是的，我也一样。我很高兴我不是一个人。也许有一天吧。
So the Blackberry obviously was a complete rethinking of the way that we communicate. And the blackberry starts out as a two-way pager. And this brilliant scientist engineer, Mike Lazaridis, figures out that they could actually use this device for work emails. So they launch it, it skyrockets in popularity. I think we can both remember a time when basically everyone you knew had a blackberry. And they just dominated the market.
所以黑莓显然是对我们交流方式的一次彻底重新构想。黑莓最初是一款双向寻呼机。这位才华横溢的科学家兼工程师迈克·拉扎里迪斯发现，他们实际上可以将这个设备用于工作邮件。于是他们推出了这款产品，其受欢迎程度急剧飙升。我想我们俩都还记得这样一个时代：基本上你认识的每个人都有一部黑莓。它们一度统治了整个市场。
And then blackberry fell apart because Mike and his colleagues were unwilling to rethink the very things that had made Blackberry great. It's this stuff right here. They all have these keyboards that are there whether you need them or not to be there. But what we're gonna do is get rid of all these buttons and just make a giant screen.
然后黑莓分崩离析了，因为迈克和他的同事们不愿意重新审视那些曾让黑莓辉煌一时的核心要素。就是这些东西。无论你需要与否，它们都有这些键盘。但我们要做的，是去掉所有这些按钮，只做一个巨大的屏幕。
A giant screen. They could not wrap their minds around the idea that people would want a touchscreen. And as late as 2008, 2009, 2010, 2011, when the iPhone has exploded in popularity, there's still having arguments about with Mike as co-founder and co-CEO saying, well, I get this holding up his blackberry and his keyboard, and then the iPhone looking at that and saying, I don't get this. They just got locked into the set of assumptions that what people wanted out of a blackberry
一个巨大的屏幕。他们的脑海里根本无法接受人们会想要一个触控屏幕的想法。直到2008年、2009年、2010年、2011年，当iPhone的人气爆炸式增长时，他们仍然在争论，作为联合创始人兼联席CEO的迈克举着他的黑莓和键盘说，嗯，我懂这个，然后看着iPhone说，我不懂这个。他们只是被这样一组假设所禁锢：人们对黑莓的需求
was a device for basically work email, as opposed to essentially a computer in your pocket for home entertainment. Right. And they really missed that opportunity to think again. as opposed to essentially a computer in your pocket for home entertainment. Right. And they really missed that opportunity to think again. ... Our reluctance to think again can have even bigger stakes.
基本上是一款用于工作邮件的设备，而不是本质上是一台放在口袋里的用于家庭娱乐的计算机。没错。他们确实错失了再次思考的机会。……而不是本质上是一台放在口袋里的用于家庭娱乐的计算机。没错。他们确实错失了再次思考的机会。……我们不愿再次思考，可能会带来更大的代价。
In the 1980s, NASA downplayed a brewing problem in the spacecraft Challenger. Since the spacecraft had completed many missions, officials assumed it was safe. But in January 1986, the spacecraft exploded moments after liftoff, killing seven astronauts on board. We have a report from the flight dynamics officer that the vehicle has exploded. Flight director confirms that we are out looking at checking with the recovery forces to see what can be done at this point.
在20世纪80年代，美国国家航空航天局（NASA）对“挑战者”号航天器中酝酿的问题轻描淡写。由于该航天器已经完成了多次任务，官员们认为它是安全的。但在1986年1月，航天器在升空后不久爆炸，导致机上七名宇航员遇难。我们收到了飞行动力学官员的报告，称飞行器已经爆炸。飞行主任确认我们正在了解情况，并与救援部队核实此时可以采取什么措施。
Or take the US war in Iraq, where President George W. Bush and his colleagues fail to rethink their views after their initial, rosy expectations of the war. We will, in fact, be greeted as liberators. Fail to materialize. Adam cites another tragedy, the Vietnam War. In the early 1960s, diplomat George Ball warned President John F. Kennedy and then President Lyndon Johnson about the risks of entering and escalating the war.
或者以美国发动的伊拉克战争为例，乔治·W·布什总统及其同事在对战争最初抱有玫瑰色般美好的期望却未能实现后，没能重新审视他们的观点。我们实际上将作为解放者受到欢迎。未能实现。亚当举了另一个悲剧的例子，即越南战争。在20世纪60年代初，外交官乔治·鲍尔曾警告约翰·F·肯尼迪总统以及后来的林登·约翰逊总统介入并升级战争的风险。
He foresaw that if the United States went forward with the war, leaders would later have trouble rethinking that position. It's chilling. Basically, he writes this at the early phase decision of, should we even enter the Vietnam or not? He's an undersecretary at the time. It was a difficult time because as time went on, I found myself more and more isolated because I was the only one that was urging this kind of a policy.
他预见到，如果美国继续推进这场战争，领导人日后将难以重新审视这一立场。这令人不寒而栗。基本上，他在是否应该介入越南战争的早期决策阶段就写下了这些。他当时是一名副国务卿。那是一段艰难的时期，随着时间的推移，我发现自己越来越孤立，因为我是唯一一个力主这种政策的人。
And he basically says, look, when I'm afraid it's going to happen is that we're going to send some initial troops to war and people are going to die. And then we've sent our own people to die. That can't have been for nothing. And so then we're going to have to send more people and invest more resources. And we're going to get trapped in this escalation of commitment to a war that didn't need to be fought in the first place.
他基本上是说，听着，我担心的是，我们将派遣一些最初的部队参战，然后人们会牺牲。接着我们又派遣了我们自己的人去送死。这总不能毫无意义吧。因此，我们接下来将不得不派遣更多的人员，投入更多的资源。我们将陷入对一场原本根本不该打的战争的不断升级的承诺中，无法自拔。
And my understanding is most historians and political scientists now would tell you that's exactly what happened. When we come back, we look at why rethinking is psychologically painful and how to help ourselves and others overcome this pain. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. Psychologist Adam Grant is the author of Think Again, a book about the virtues of rethinking oppositions.
据我了解，大多数历史学家和政治学家现在都会告诉你，这正是当时发生的事情。稍后回来，我们将探讨为什么重新思考在心理上是痛苦的，以及如何帮助自己和他人克服这种痛苦。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。心理学家亚当·格兰特是《再次思考》一书的作者，该书探讨了重新审视反对意见的美德。
We've seen how not being open to rethinking our beliefs can have major consequences in our personal, professional and political lives. Adam, I want to talk about some of the drivers of obstinacy in our lives. I know that you're a fan of the TV show Seinfeld, and there's a famous scene which features a restaurant owner who is called the soup Nazi. Not soup for you!
我们已经看到，不愿对我们的信念进行重新思考，会在我们的个人、职业和政治生活中产生重大的后果。亚当，我想谈谈我们生活中导致执拗的一些驱动因素。我知道你是电视剧《宋飞传》的粉丝，其中有一个著名的场景，里面有一个餐馆老板被称为“汤面纳粹”。不给你们汤喝！
He makes great soup, but he cannot tolerate the slightest criticism or deviation from the script. I want to play you a short clip where the character Elaine visits the soup Nazi. One mulligatani, and what is that right there? Is that lima bean? Yes. Never been a big fan. big fan. So the Sook Nazi illustrates something that you talk about Adam, the difference between relationship conflict and task conflict. What is this difference? I'm suddenly craving some mulligatani, but we'll get back to that.
他做的汤很好喝，但他容不得对剧本的丝毫批评或偏离。我想放一段简短的剪辑，其中角色伊莲拜访了汤面纳粹。一份闷牛肉汤，那是什么？那是利马豆吗？是的。从来都不是它的超级粉丝。……所以汤面纳粹展现了你所讨论的亚当的一个概念，即关系冲突和任务冲突之间的区别。这种区别是什么？我突然有点想吃闷牛肉汤了，不过我们待会儿再谈这个。
Let's talk about task and relationship conflict. Most of us, especially those of us who are agreeable, when we think about conflict, we're thinking about relationship conflict. Most of us, especially those of us who are agreeable, when we think about conflict, we're thinking about relationship conflict. That's the personal, emotional, I think you're a terrible person, and my life would be better if I never had to interact with you kind of clashed that a lot of us run into. There's another kind of conflict though that an organizational psychologist named Eddie Jen and her colleagues have studied task conflict. I mean, it's the idea of debating about different opinions and perspectives. It's potentially constructive because it's actually about trying to get to the truth.
让我们来谈谈任务冲突和关系冲突。我们大多数人，尤其是我们这些随和的人，当我们在思考冲突时，我们想到的都是关系冲突。我们大多数人，尤其是我们这些随和的人，当我们在思考冲突时，我们想到的都是关系冲突。那是那种个人的、情感上的冲突，也就是“我觉得你是个糟糕的人，如果我永远不必跟你互动，我的生活会更好”，这是我们许多人都会遇到的一种冲突。不过还有另一种冲突，由一位名叫珍·艾迪的组织心理学家和她的同事们研究过，叫做任务冲突。我的意思是，这是围绕不同意见和视角进行辩论的想法。它具有潜在的建设性，因为它实际上是为了探寻真理。
It's not personal, it's not emotional. We're not trying to beat up the other person. We're not feeling like we're being attacked. We're trying to hash out or sort out different views through what might be a feisty conversation, but it's intellectual. And I think one of the biggest problems that the soup Nazi had is he could not have a task conflict without it becoming relationship conflict. The moment that you object to his line or that you don't follow his rules, he takes it very personally and bans you from his super oasis.
这不是针对个人的，也不是情绪化的。我们不是为了打倒对方。我们没有觉得自己受到了攻击。我们试图通过一场可能很激烈的对话来厘清或整理不同的观点，但它是理性的。我认为汤面纳粹最大的问题之一，在于他无法进行任务冲突，而不会让其演变成关系冲突。就在你反对他的台词或者没有遵守他的规矩的那一刻，他会非常走心，并把你从他的汤品绿洲中驱逐出去。
Is that how you interpreted it as well? That's exactly how I interpreted it. I mean, Elaine has many problems as a character, of course, but the fact that she's basically saying she's not a fan of lima beans, that is not necessarily a reflection on, you know, the soup Nazi's character. It just means that there's a customer who doesn't like something that you made. It's not a big deal, but he can't take a criticism or a disagreement as just saying, all right, someone has a different opinion than I do. He has to take everything personally. And Adam, you've surveyed teams of workers in Silicon Valley about conflict and examine
你也是这么解读的吗？我完全是这么解读的。我的意思是，伊莲作为角色当然有很多问题，但她基本上是说自己不喜欢利马豆，这并不一定是在映射汤面纳粹的人格。这只意味着这里有一个顾客不喜欢你做的事。这没什么大不了的，但他无法把批评或分歧仅仅当作“好吧，有人和我持不同意见”。他必须把一切都针对个人。亚当，你曾在硅谷的员工团队中调查过冲突，并研究了
which groups perform well and which ones don't. And you found that the way they handle task conflict and relationship conflict is often behind successful teams and unsuccessful teams. Can you explain to me what you found? Yeah, I think the mistake that a lot of people make is they assume that less conflict is better. That if you want to build a successful collaboration
哪些团队表现好，哪些团队表现不好。你发现，他们处理任务冲突和关系冲突的方式往往是成功团队和不成功团队背后的原因。你能向我解释一下你发现了什么吗？是的，我认为很多人犯的错误是他们认为冲突越少越好。如果你想建立一个成功的合作关系
or a great team, then you want to minimize the amount of tension you have. But as some researchers have argued based on a lot of evidence, the absence of conflict is not harmony, it's apathy. If you're in a group where people never disagree, the only way that could really happen is if people don't care enough to speak their minds. And so, in order to get to wise decisions, creative solutions, we need to hear a variety of perspectives, we need diversity of thought.
或一个伟大的团队，那么你就要尽量减少紧张局势。但正如一些研究人员根据大量证据所论证的那样，没有冲突并不叫和谐，那叫冷漠。如果你在一个人们从不意见不一的群体里，真正导致这种情况的唯一原因，其实是大家根本不在乎到懒得说出自己的想法。因此，为了做出明智的决策和创造性的解决方案，我们需要听到各种不同的观点，我们需要思想的多样性。
And task conflict is one of the ways that we get there. By saying, you know what? I think we actually don't agree on what the vision for our company should be, or what our strategy should be, or how to design this product. And so let's hash that out. And I don't think we do that enough. So in the study that I did, I tracked team performance
而任务冲突就是我们实现这一目标的方式之一。通过说，“你知道吗？我觉得我们其实并不赞同公司愿景应该是什么，或者战略应该是什么，又或者如何设计这个产品。所以让我们把它争论清楚。”我觉得我们在这方面做得还不够在我做的这项研究中，我追踪了团队的绩效
over a number of months. And I surveyed people and teams on how often they were having relationship conflict as well as task conflict. Even if they agreed on nothing else, they agreed on what kind of conflict they were having and how much of it. And it turned out in the failed groups,
持续了好几个月。我对团队中的人们进行了调查，了解他们发生关系冲突以及任务冲突的频率。即使他们在其他任何事情上都无法达成一致，他们也认同他们正在经历的是哪种冲突以及冲突的程度。结果发现在那些失败的团队中，
they tended to have a lot more relationship conflict than task conflict. Especially early on, they were so busy disliking each other that they didn't really have substantive debates until about halfway through the lifecycle of their project, and by then it was almost too late to change course. Whereas in the high performing groups, they started out with very little relationship conflict and plenty of task conflict saying, look, before we design a product, we really want to get all the ideas on the table about how we might do it or what it might before. And then once they sorted those out, they were able to really focus and align around what
他们的关系冲突往往比任务冲突要多得多。特别是在早期，他们忙于互相厌烦，以至于直到项目生命周期过半左右，他们都没有进行真正实质性的辩论，而到了那时，想要改变航向几乎为时已晚。而在那些表现优异的团队中，他们开始时关系冲突极少，而任务冲突却很充分，他们会说：“看，在我们设计产品之前，我们真的想把所有关于我们该如何做、或者它应该是什么样子的想法都摆到桌面上来。”一旦他们把这些问题理清了，他们就能真正专注于他们的共同使命，并与之保持一致。随着时间的推移，他们能够说：“好吧，随着我们意见不一的各种问题不断出现，我们将再进行一次辩论。
their common mission was. And they were able then, over time, to say, okay, as different issues crop up that we disagree on, we're gonna have another debate. And we're gonna hear each other's views again, and that ultimately gave them a better shot at working on something that was really promising. So I hear you say sort of two things about relationship conflicts that are pernicious.
我们将再次倾听彼此的观点，”这最终让他们有更好的机会去致力于一些真正有前景的事情。所以，我听到你说的关于关系冲突的两点是有害的。
One is that in the presence of relationship conflict, people shut down and don't voice the concerns that they have that could be useful for the performance of the group. But the second thing is when task conflict concerns are raised, when you have relationship conflicts, those are likely to be interpreted through the lens of relationship conflict. In other words, someone raises an issue with something that the group is doing and people behave like the soup Nazi, they react and take things personally. Yeah, that is a very clear and elegant summary of what I think the research points to where when a disagreement becomes personal, everything that gets raised by the other person is interpreted in the most negative light possible.
其一是，在存在关系冲突的情况下，人们会关闭心扉，不再表达那些可能对团队绩效有用的担忧。但第二点是，当提出任务冲突相关的担忧时，如果你存在关系冲突，这些担忧很可能会通过关系冲突的视角来解读。换句话说，当有人对团队正在做的事情提出问题时，人们表现得就像汤面纳粹一样，他们会有所反应并把事情归咎于个人。是的，这是对我认为研究所指向的方向的一个非常清晰且精辟的总结：当分歧变得个人化时，对方提出的任何意见都会以最负面的眼光被解读。
And then I think the other problem is people sometimes just, they don't even hear the substance of the idea because they're so invested in defending their ego or in proving the other person wrong. There's a related idea to this distinction between task conflict and relationship conflict that you explore in your book Adam. You say that one reason it's hard to admit we are wrong is that we sometimes confuse
然后我认为另一个问题是，人们有时甚至根本听不到想法的实质，因为他们太专注于捍卫自己的自尊或证明对方是错的。与任务冲突和关系冲突之间的这种区别相关的一个想法，你在书中也进行了探讨，亚当。你说，我们很难承认自己错了的原因之一，有时是我们混淆了
our beliefs with our values. What do you mean by those terms? Okay. So when I think about a belief, I would say that's something that you take as true. A value is something you think is important. And yeah, I think a lot of us make a mistake of taking our beliefs and opinions and making them our identity. And since I spend a lot of time studying the workplace, I really enjoy thinking about how dangerous the world would be. If people in the professions that we rely on every day did that.
我们的信念与我们的价值观。你这些术语是什么意思？好的。所以当我想到信念时，我会说那是你认为是真实的东西。而价值观则是你认为重要的东西。是的，我想我们很多人都犯了一个错误，把我们的信念和观点变成了我们的身份认同。由于我花了很多时间研究职场，我真的很喜欢去思考，如果我们每天依赖的职业中的人们也这样做，这个世界将会变得多么危险。
So let's say you were a doctor, I don't know, half a century ago or more. I would not want to go to you if your identity was professional lobotomist. Right. If you're somebody who carries this belief that the right way to treating anxiety or other kinds of problems
所以假设你是一名医生，我不知道，半个世纪前或更久以前。如果你的身份是一名专业的脑白质切除术医生，我可不想去看你。没错。如果你是一个坚信治疗焦虑或其他类型问题的正确方法
is to just remove your frontal lobe or part of it, that's probably not gonna go well. And so I wanna see the doctor who's open about beliefs, who says, well, I wanna learn from the best evidence about how to treat this problem, but who's committed to and has conviction around a value of protecting and promoting health and safety. And you can do the same thing with all kinds of other jobs.
就是切除你的额叶或其一部分的人，那可能不会有什么好结果。所以我希望能看到这样的医生：他们对信念持开放态度，说“我想从关于如何治疗这个问题的最佳证据中学习”，但他们同时也致力于并坚信保护和促进健康与安全的价值观。你可以对各种其他工作采取同样的方法。
I definitely would not want my community policed by an officer who sees herself as a stop and frisker. And there are examples of leaders who basically model what it's like to have task conflict without relationship conflict. I was thinking of something that President Obama said some years ago when he invited someone he disagreed with to play a prominent role in his administration we're not going to agree
我绝对不希望我的社区由一个把自己视为“拦截搜查”专家的警官来巡逻。有一些领导者的例子，他们基本上展示了如何在没有关系冲突的情况下进行任务冲突。我想到了奥巴马总统几年前说过的一句话，当时他邀请了一位与他意见不合的人在政府中扮演重要角色：我们不会在每一个单一问题上都达成一致，
on every single issue what we have to do is to be able to create an atmosphere where we can disagree uh... without being disagreeable and then focus on those things that we hold in common as americans to disagree without being disagreeable and then focus on those things that we hold in common as Americans. To disagree without being disagreeable, I think many of us forget this lesson at them. We think that if someone else is wrong, our job is just to correct them. How we correct them is unimportant. Yeah, I think that's such a common mistake in communication.
我们必须要做的是，创造一种能够让我们产生分歧的氛围，而又不会显得不随和，然后专注于我们作为美国人所共同拥有的那些事情。做到存在分歧却不显得不随和，我想我们许多人都忘记了这个教训，亚当。我们认为，如果别人错了，我们的工作就是纠正他们。我们如何纠正他们并不重要。是的，我认为这是交流中非常常见的一个错误。
We think it's the message that matters, but so often, whether somebody's willing to hear a message depends on who's saying it, why it's being said, and how it's being delivered. And I cannot tell you, Sean, the number of times that I have rejected useful criticism because I didn't trust the person who was giving it to me, Or they delivered it in a way that I found disrespectful or offensive. And that was a missed opportunity for both of us. Not all of us listen to useful feedback, even when it's presented clearly and without ranker. That's because we confuse challenges to our views
我们认为重要的是信息本身，但通常情况下，别人是否愿意倾听信息，取决于谁在说、为什么要说，以及它是如何传达的。尚卡尔，我简直无法告诉你我有多少次拒绝了有用的批评，因为我不信任向我提供批评的人，或者他们表达的方式让我觉得不尊重或被冒犯。这让我们两个人都错失了良机。并不是所有人都会听取有用的反馈，即使这些反馈表达得清晰且不带怨恨。这是因为我们将对我们观点的挑战
with threats to our ego. There's a term that I love for this, which comes out of psychology. It's originally a Tony Greenwald's term. It's the totalitarian ego. And the idea is that all of us have an inner dictator policing our thoughts. And the dictator's job is to keep out threatening information much like Kim Jong-un would control the press in North Korea.
混淆为了对我们自尊的威胁。有一个我非常喜欢的心理学术语来形容这一点。它最初是托尼·格林瓦尔德的一个术语。这就是极权自我。这个想法是，我们所有人都有一个内心独裁者在监管我们的想法。独裁者的工作是把具有威胁性的信息挡在外面，就像金正恩在朝鲜控制新闻那样。
And when your core belief surattacked, the inner dictator comes in and rescues you with mental armor and activates confirmation bias where you only see what you expected to see all along triggers desirability bias where you only see what you wanted to see all along and you can feel like you're not under threat after all. You can see the totalitarian ego at work in a study conducted some years ago by researchers in Australia.
当你的核心信念受到攻击时，内心独裁者就会介入，用心理铠甲拯救你，并激活确认偏误，让你只看到你一直期待看到的东西，触发合意偏误（desirability bias），让你只看到你一直希望看到的东西，并且你会觉得自己毕竟没有受到威胁。你可以在几年前澳大利亚研究人员进行的一项研究中看到极权自我的运作。
The asked volunteers to think of a time when they did something wrong and apologized for it, and to also think about a time when they did something wrong and did not apologize for it. Research a Tyler Rocky Moto explains what they found. When you refuse to apologize, it actually makes you feel more empowered. That power and control seems to translate into greater feelings of self-worth. And in some ways, the sounds like the inner dictator, when we apologize in some ways, we are disarming ourselves and when we refuse to apologize in some ways, we are mounting
他们要求志愿者回想他们做错事并道歉的一次经历，以及回想他们做错事但没有道歉的一次经历。研究员泰勒·罗基莫托解释了他们的发现。当你拒绝道歉时，它实际上会让你感觉更有力量。这种权力和控制似乎转化为了更强的自我价值感。在某些方面，这听起来像是内心独裁者，当我们道歉时，在某种程度上，我们是在解除自己的武装；而当我们拒绝道歉时，在某种程度上，我们是在构筑
a form of emotional self-defense. Yeah, sadly, staying attached to our wrong convictions makes us feel strong. And psychologists have also found for decades that the act of resisting influence only further fortifies our convictions because we can, we basically get inoculated against future attacks. We have all of our defenses ready and we end up sealing our beliefs in an ever more impenetrable fortress. We've talked about a number of different drivers of
一种情感上的自我防卫。是的，可悲的是，固守错误的信念会让我们感到强大。心理学家几十年来也发现，抵抗影响的行为只会进一步巩固我们的信念，因为我们可以——我们基本上接种了疫苗，可以抵御未来的攻击。我们做好了所有的防御准备，最终将我们的信念封锁在一个越来越坚不可摧的堡垒中。我们讨论了许多不同的
obscenity and stubbornness, our inability to question our own beliefs. I want to talk a moment about the role of identity and stereotypes. Can you talk about how these things are loyalty to different groups, our membership in different tribes, can keep us in some ways from challenging, you know, dearly held beliefs or cherished beliefs, and in some ways keep us from rethinking our views? Yeah. from rethinking our views. Yeah, so I have a brilliant colleague, Phil Tetlock, who wrote a paper about how almost every decision you've ever made, almost every opinion you've ever formed,
执拗和顽固的驱动因素，也就是我们质疑自己信念能力的缺乏。我想花点时间谈谈身份认同和刻板印象的作用。你能谈谈这些东西——对不同群体的忠诚、我们在不同部落中的成员身份——如何在某种程度上阻止我们挑战（你知道的）深信不疑的信念或珍视的信念，并在某种程度上阻止我们重新思考自己的观点吗？是的。阻止我们重新思考自己的观点。是的，我有一位才华横溢的同事菲尔·泰特洛克，他写过一篇论文，探讨了几乎你做过的每一个决定、几乎你形成的每一个观点，
is influenced by your relationship to the people around you and by the groups that you're part of and the identities that you hold about who you are in the social world. And what Phil observed is we often spend time thinking like preachers, prosecutors, and politicians. Preaching is basically defending a set of sacred beliefs and saying, look, I found the truth,
都受到你与周围人的关系、你所属的群体以及你对自己在社会世界中是谁的身份认同的影响。菲尔观察到的是，我们经常花时间像传教士、检察官和政客一样思考。传教士基本上是在捍卫一套神圣的信念，并说：“看，我找到了真理，
my job is to proselytize it. I just didn't make any difference if the church is today of stop preaching on hell. If the preachers don't preach on hell, to proselytize it. Prosecuting is the reverse. It's saying, okay, my job is to prove you wrong and win my case with the best argument. For this man to skirt financial and moral responsibility because he found a scuzzy lawyer and a scuzzier Shrink to pronounce him disabled for for this man to waltz into a court and get an order saying that this woman was never married when she let an
我的工作就是去宣扬它。”今天教堂里是否停止宣教地狱已经不重要了。如果传教士不宣教地狱，那就去宣扬它。检察官则正好相反。它是在说：“好吧，我的工作就是证明你错了，用最好的论据赢得我的案子。”……为了让这个人逃避财务和道德责任，因为他找了一个卑鄙的律师和一个更卑鄙的精神病医生来宣布他残疾……为了这个人趾高气扬地走进法院并得到一项命令，宣称这个女人从未结过婚，而她过着
exemplary married life. How dare you live and Anytime we're part of a group that has strong beliefs It's pretty unlikely that we're going to rethink any opinions or decisions as we get into preacher or prosecutor mode because we already know. I already know. I'm right and you're wrong. We're a little more flexible when we shift into politician mode. Look at this. What is it? They're calling you the no BSVP. Damn right there. I mean, I lied and everything, but it sounded true at least. Because when you're thinking like a politician, what you're trying to do is get the approval
堪称楷模的婚姻生活。你怎么敢活……任何时候，只要我们属于一个拥有强烈信念的群体，当我们进入传教士或检察官模式时，我们就不太可能重新思考任何观点或决定，因为我们已经知道了。我早就知道我对了，而你错了。当我们切换到政客模式时，我们会更有灵活性。瞧这个。这是什么？他们叫你“零废话副总统”。说得太对了。我的意思是，我撒谎了什么的，但听起来至少是真的。因为当你像政客一样思考时，你试图做的是获得
of an audience that you care about. And so you might be campaigning and lobbying, and sometimes that means adjusting and flexing at least what you say you believe in order to fit in and win them over. The problem is that we're doing it because we want to prove our allegiance to a tribe, not because we're trying to get closer to the truth. Coming up, strategies to help us rethink our own views and how to help others reconsider their cherished opinions. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta.
你关心的受众的批准。所以你可能在进行竞选和游说，有时这意味着调整和变通，至少调整你所说你相信的东西，以便融入其中并赢得他们的支持。问题在于，我们这样做是因为我们想证明自己对某个部落的忠诚，而不是因为我们试图更接近真理。接下来的节目中，我们将探讨帮助我们重新思考自己观点的策略，以及如何帮助他人重新审视他们珍视的观点。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
University of Pennsylvania's psychologist Adam Grant has written a book about the power of searching for the flaws in our own beliefs and arguments, of challenging deeply held views. Many of us have trouble doing this, and the echo chambers that surround us usually don't reward us for being reflective and adaptable. But history shows that if we check out personal egos we can make important discoveries. Adam, you tell the story of Orville and Wilbur Wright, the brothers who invented the first successful airplane. Can you describe their relationship to me and how it bears on the conversation we're having? Of all the moments in history that I would love to witness, I think watching the Wright Brothers
宾夕法尼亚大学的心理学家亚当·格兰特写了一本关于寻找我们自己信念和论据中的缺陷、挑战深层观点的力量的书。我们许多人在这方面都有困难，周围的回声室通常不会因为我们有反思能力和适应能力而奖励我们。但历史表明，如果我们放下个人自尊，就能做出重要的发现。亚当，你讲述了奥ville和威尔伯·莱 Wright（奥维尔和威尔伯·莱特兄弟）的故事，这对发明了第一架成功飞机的兄弟。你能向我描述一下他们的关系以及它与我们正在进行的对话有什么关系吗？在历史上的所有时刻中，我最想亲眼目睹的时刻之一，
argue would be pretty high on my list. So if you look at the history of what the Wright Brothers created together, it seemed like they were constantly in sync. They created their own printing press together, they ran their own bicycle shop They created their own printing press together, they ran their own bicycle shop, they made their own bikes together, they launched a newspaper together, and of course, we all know they invented the first at least successful airplane together.
我想看莱特兄弟争论应该会在我的愿望清单上名列前茅。所以如果你看看莱特兄弟共同创造的历史，似乎他们总是步调一致。他们一起创建了自己的印刷厂，他们一起经营自己的自行车行，
And I always assumed that they were just lucky to have such harmony. And yet, if you read any of the biographies that have been written about them, if you read their own letters and personal communications, if you read the stories and the anecdotes from people who knew them well, it was very clear that arguing was their default mode and it was almost the family business. And what I think is fascinating about the Wright Brothers is they mastered the ability to have productive task conflicts without it spilling into relationship conflict.
他们一起制作自己的自行车，他们一起创办了一份报纸，当然，我们都知道他们一起发明了至少是第一架成功的飞机。而我总是认为，他们只是幸运地拥有如此和谐的关系。然而，如果你读过任何为他们写过的传记，如果你读过他们自己的信件和私人通信，如果你读过那些了解他们的人的故事和轶事，就会非常清楚：争论是他们的默认模式，这几乎成了他们的家族企业。我认为莱特兄弟最迷人的是，他们掌握了进行富有成效的任务冲突的能力，而不会让其演变成关系冲突。
It was typical for them when they were trying to invent their airplane to argue for weeks about questions like, how do you design a propeller? And they would sometimes even shout for hours back and forth and at one point their sister threatened to leave the house because she just couldn't take it anymore. But they seem to get a kick out of it. They called it scrapping. And they said, look, a whole point of an argument is it helps both people see more clearly if you do it well. They never saw an argument as personal.
他们在试图发明飞机时，为了诸如“如何设计螺旋桨”之类的问题争论上几个星期，这是他们的常态。他们有时甚至会来来回回大喊大叫好几个小时，有一次他们的妹妹甚至威胁要离家出走，因为她实在受不了了。但他们似乎乐在其中。他们把这叫做“吵架”（scrapping）。他们说，看，争论的全部意义在于，如果你做得好，它能帮助双方看得更清楚。他们从不把争论当作个人恩怨。
The mechanic used to phrase that I think about almost every day. He said, I don't think they really got mad, but they sure got awfully hot. And that, to me, captures the passion, the energy, the feistiness that goes into, you know, duking out a set of ideas that's really important to you. But not leaving that interaction angry. Hmm. Now not all of us have the benefit of having, you know, a sibling, you know, real or metaphorical who can play this role for us.
那位机械师用过的一个词组，我几乎每天都会想起。他说：“我觉得他们并没有真的生气，但他们的确火药味十足。”对我来说，这捕捉到了将一系列对你非常重要的理念进行辩论时所投入的激情、能量和好胜心。但他们并没有带着愤怒结束互动。嗯。现在，我们并不是所有人都有幸拥有一个兄弟姐妹（无论现实中还是隐喻意义上的），能够为我们扮演这个角色。
We don't have a partner maybe who can help us rethink our views. But all of us are often part of organizations and part of teams. Or we can be part of organizations and teams that in some ways can play the same role for us. You tell the story of Steve Jobs, the co-founder of Apple, obviously, a brilliant visionary, but he was also famously stubborn. He was also prone to the first instinct fallacy, and very nearly came close to not inventing the iPhone. Can you tell me what happened and how Steve's mind got changed? Sure, when you think about your network, we all have a support network.
我们身边可能没有那种能帮我们重新审视观点的人。但我们所有人往往都是组织和团队的一部分。或者我们可以加入这样的组织和团队，它们在某种程度上能为我们扮演相同的角色。你讲了苹果联合创始人史蒂夫·乔布斯的历史，他显然是一位杰出的有远见的领袖，但他也出了名的固执。他还容易陷入第一直觉谬误，差点就没发明出iPhone。你能告诉我当时发生了什么，以及史蒂夫是如何改变主意的吗？当然，当你思考自己的人脉网络时，我们都有一个支持网络。
That's usually the highly agreeable people who we know are gonna have our back and really lift us up or pick us up when we're down. I think what we overlook is that we also need a challenge network, which is a group of people that we trust to question us, to point out the holes in our thinking, the flaws in our logic, the ways that our decisions might be leading us astray from our goals. And it's not clear to me that Steve Jobs did this intentionally, but he was very lucky to be surrounded with a group of people who played that role of a challenge network for him.
那通常是那些高度赞同我们的人，我们知道他们会支持我们，在我们情绪低落时真正振奋我们或拉我们一把。我认为我们忽视的是，我们同样需要一个质疑网络，这是一群我们信任的人，他们会质问我们，指出我们思维中的漏洞、逻辑上的缺陷，以及我们的决策可能让我们背离目标的种种方式。我并不清楚史蒂夫·乔布斯是否有意这样做，但他非常幸运，身边围绕着一群为他扮演质疑网络角色的人。
What I do all day is meet with teams of people and work on ideas and solve problems to make new products, to make new marketing programs, whatever it is. And are people willing to tell you you're wrong? Yeah. I mean, other than snarky journalists. I mean, people that work for you. Oh, yeah. No, we have wonderful arguments.
我整天都在做的事情就是与团队开会，共同研究创意、解决问题，以打造新产品、制定新的营销方案，诸如此类。人们愿意对你说你是错的吗？会啊。我是说，除了那些尖酸刻薄的记者。我是说那些为你工作的人。哦，会啊。不，我们经常有精彩的争论。
And do you win them all? Oh, no. I wish I did. And he was dead set against making a phone. He complained for years about how smartphones were for the pocket protector crowd. And Apple makes cool products. We don't want to touch that. He could rant for hours at a time about how everybody was beholden to the cell phone carriers
那你每次都赢吗？哦，没有。我希望我能赢。他曾经坚决反对生产手机。他抱怨了好几年，说智能手机是给那些别着钢笔护袋的极客准备的。苹果生产的是酷炫的产品。我们才不想碰那玩意儿。他可以连续几个小时大发雷霆，痛斥所有人都受制于移动运营商，
and they didn't know how to make an elegant product. And sometimes he would even throw his own phone against the wall and shatter it because he was so frustrated with how bad the technology was. Luckily, I think for Apple and for anybody who's a fan of the iPhone or the iPad, he surrounded himself with brilliant engineers and designers who knew how to get him to think again. You have to be run by ideas, not hierarchy. The best ideas have to win. And a lot of the things that they did as part of his challenge network are things that we've seen people do every day.
而且他们根本不懂怎么做出优雅的产品。有时他甚至会把自己的手机怒摔在墙上摔得粉碎，因为他对那糟糕的技术感到无比沮丧。幸运的是，我想对苹果公司来说，对任何喜爱iPhone或iPad的人来说，他身边聚集了一群杰出的工程师和设计师，他们知道如何让他重新思考。你必须由创意驱动，而不是层级结构。最好的创意必须获胜。他们在作为他的质疑网络时所做的大量事情，都是我们看到人们每天都在做的事情。
They would plant seeds. They would say, hey, I hear Microsoft is talking about making a phone. How ugly do you think that's gonna be? And if we ever made one of those, what would that look like? They would ask questions like, you know, hey, we did the iPod, we've already put 20,000 songs in your pocket. What if we put everything in your pocket?
他们会埋下种子。他们会说，嘿，我听说微软在讨论做一款手机。你觉得那会有多丑？如果我们也做一款，它会是什么样子的？他们会问一些这样的问题，你知道的，嘿，我们做出了iPod，已经把两万首歌装进了你的口袋。如果我们把所有东西都装进你的口袋会怎么样？
And what they were doing was they were activating its curiosity. If you they were doing was they were activating his curiosity. If you told him he was wrong, he would immediately go into prosecutor mode, right? And tear your argument apart. If you told him about your idea, he would preach about his idea. But if you could ask a question that intrigued him and let him realize that he didn't know some things. He might then go out and try to discover them or give you the green light to go and discover them.
他们当时在做的是激活他的好奇心。如果你直接告诉他他错了，他会立刻进入检察官模式，对吧？然后把你的论点批得体无完肤。如果你向他倾诉你的想法，他就会开始长篇大论地宣讲他自己的想法。但如果你能提出一个引发他兴趣的问题，让他意识到自己有些事情并不了解，他可能就会亲自去探索，或者给你开绿灯让你去探索。
And those kinds of conversations finally got him to reverse course and make a phone. You know lots of us in some ways make the same mistake that Steve Jobs made. We sort of respond as you say, like prosecutors, or we respond defensively, like preachers, if our views are challenged. You've done some exploration into how we can change the views of the people around us. And some of that, you just spoke about a second ago, some of the techniques in some way seem almost coming at the issue sideways rather than head on. And this is again somewhat odd because I understand that you sometimes have been called a logic bully. Can you tell me how you
正是这类对话最终让他改变方向，制造出了一款手机。你知道，我们很多人在某种程度上都犯了史蒂夫·乔布斯曾犯过的错误。如果我们的观点受到挑战，我们就会像你所说的那样，像检察官一样作出回应，或者像传教士一样进行防御性的回应。你对我们如何改变周围人的观点做了一些探索。其中一些，你刚才已经提到了，有些技巧在某种程度上似乎与其正面迎击，不如说有点像是从侧面切入。这再次显得有点奇怪，因为据我所悉，有时你甚至被称为逻辑霸凌者。你能告诉我你是怎么
got that nickname adamant and what you have discovered about the effectiveness of logic in changing people's minds? I certainly can. I had a former student named Jamie Callmys for some career advice. And it was clear in the first minute or so of our conversation that she was already locked into the plan that she had made. And I was worried that she might be making a decision that she would regret.
得到这个绰号的吗？对于逻辑在改变人们想法方面的有效性，你又发现了什么？我当然可以。我以前有个学生叫杰米·卡尔米斯，她来寻求一些职业建议。在我们谈话的第一分钟左右，就很明显她已经固守于她自己做好的计划了。我担心她可能会做一个日后会后悔的决定。
And so I just told her, you know, here are all the reasons why I think you're making a potentially big mistake. Well, she listened patiently for, I think, two or three minutes and then she said, you're a logic bully. A logic what? A logic bully. She said that I overwhelmed her with rational arguments and data and she didn't agree, but she didn't feel like she could fight back.
所以我直接告诉她，你知道，以下是我认为你在犯一个潜在重大错误的所有理由。好吧，她耐心地听了大概两三分钟，然后她说：“你是个逻辑霸凌者。”一个什么？一个逻辑霸凌者。她说我用理性的论据和数据把她压得喘不过气来，她虽然不同意，但觉得自己无力反击。
I think when I learned from that experienced shocker, you can't really bully someone into changing their mind. And even if you could, you're probably just getting lip service where they're telling you what they think you wanna hear to get you to shut up, right? Because they're tired of being bullied. And I think that the questions we ask people,
我想我从那次经历中吸取到的令人震惊的教训是，你无法真正通过霸凌来改变别人的想法。即便你能做到，你可能也只是得到了言听计从的敷衍，他们只是在对你敷衍了事，说他们觉得你想听的话，好让你闭嘴，对吧？因为他们厌倦了被霸凌。我认为我们向人们提出的问题，
the humility we express in saying, you know what, there are lots of things that I'm not sure about here, the curiosity we show in trying to understand more about their own views and their motivation to change their thinking, that's where real thought happens. That's where people who might have closed their minds say, maybe, maybe I'll open it this time. Maybe I will reconsider. You've looked at people who are successful negotiators and successful debaters. What are some of the techniques they use that the rest of us might not think to do right off the bat in terms of engaging with an opponent, for example, what are some of the do's and don'ts?
我们在表达“你知道吗，这里有很多事情我也不太确定”时表现出的谦逊，我们在试图更多地了解他们的观点和改变思维的动机时表现出的好奇心，这才是真正思考发生的地方。正是这些原本思想封闭的人会说：“也许，也许这次我可以敞开心扉。也许我会重新考虑。”你观察过那些成功的谈判者和成功的辩论者。他们在与对手交锋时，有哪些是其余的我们可能不会立刻想到去做的技巧？比如，有哪些该做和不该做的事？
Okay, so there's a classic study by Neil Rackerman colleagues of expert versus average negotiators, where they compare what their habits are, and there are a few things that differentiate the experts from the average negotiators. One is they spend a lot more time, both in their planning and in their actual negotiations Thinking about common ground and talking about common ground saying we want to build areas of consensus before we find out where we're opposed
好的，尼尔·拉克曼及其同事曾做过一项关于专家与普通谈判者对比的经典研究，他们比较了各自的习惯，有几点区分出了专家和普通谈判者。第一点是，他们在规划和实际谈判中，花更多的时间去思考共同点并讨论共同点，他们会说：在我们找出分歧所在之前，我们要先建立共识领域。
They also ask a lot more questions. They'd say okay here two or three possible proposals What are your reactions to these? What do you like? What do you dislike and? What are your thoughts and that that allowed them to both learn more and again, signal more flexibility as well. I mean, it's so interesting, especially in the political sphere, but certainly not limited to the political sphere, we often think of trying to change someone's opinion with the metaphor of, you know, a tug of war, that the harder I pull, the more I can get you off balance, the more likely I am to win. And the model that you're suggesting here is a very different model. You know, model where you're asking a lot of questions,
他们还会提出更多问题。他们会说，好吧，这里有两三项可能的提案，你对这些有什么反应？你喜欢什么？你不喜欢什么？你的想法是什么？这让他们既能了解更多信息，又能再次释放出更多灵活性。我的意思是，这非常有趣，尤其是在政治领域，当然也不限于政治领域，我们经常用拔河的隐喻来试图改变别人的观点，即我拉得越用力，就能让你越失去平衡，我就越有可能获胜。而你在这里建议的模式是一种非常不同的模式。你知道，这是一种你会提出很多问题的模式，
where you're seeking common ground, where you're willing to make concessions, where you're open to figuring out how you yourself might be wrong. That's a very different model and a very different metaphor than a tug of war. It is. This is not the metaphor I would have ever come up with. But there are some psychologists who said, we should think about disagreements, less as wars, and more as dances. And I can't dance at all. I'm so bad at dancing that my wife signed
你会寻找共同点，你愿意做出让步，你愿意弄清楚你自己可能也会出错。这与拔河是一种截然不同的模式和隐喻。确实如此。这不是我能想出来的隐喻。但有一些心理学家说过，我们应该把分歧少当作战争，多当作舞蹈来看待。我完全不会跳舞。我跳舞太烂了，以至于我太太在婚礼前给我们
us up for dancing lessons before our wedding. And after the second one, she gave up. I don't have any rhythm. So I wouldn't have thought of dancing. But what I like about the dance metaphor is you know that in a dance, your job is to get in sync with your partner. And that means if you've both shown up to the dance with an idea about what steps you're going to take, you can't lead all the time and expect your partner to do all of the adjusting. Right, you actually have to be willing to step back and let your partner lead from time to time.
报了舞蹈班。但在上了第二节课后，她就放弃了。我一点节奏感都没有。所以我绝不会想到跳舞。但我喜欢舞蹈隐喻的地方在于，你知道在舞蹈中，你的任务是与舞伴保持同步。这意味着，如果你们俩带着各自对接下来要跳什么舞步的想法来到舞场，你不能一直由你来领舞，却指望舞伴来做所有的配合调整。没错，你实际上必须愿意退后一步，让舞伴时不时地引领一下。
And that's what expert negotiators seem to do. It's what great debaters seem to do. And I think it's what all of us can do more when we have polarized conversations. And I think it's what all of us can do more when we have polarized conversations. You also apply this insight in education when you think about what teachers are trying to do. Teachers are, in some ways, the whole point of education is to get people to rethink their views, to think more carefully about their positions to learn. You describe the story of a public school teacher named
这正是专家谈判者似乎在做的事情。这也是伟大的辩论者似乎在做的事情。我想这也是我们在进行两极分化的对话时，所有人都可以做得更多的事情。我想这也是我们在进行两极分化的对话时，所有人都可以做得更多的事情。你在教育中也应用了这种见解，当你思考老师们试图做什么时。老师们，在某种程度上，教育的全部意义就在于让人们重新审视自己的观点，更仔细地思考自己的立场并进行学习。你描述了一位名叫
Ron Berger, who exemplifies this idea. What does Ron do to help people think about what they're doing in new and interesting ways? So one of the things that Ron does is with his first graders, he'll ask them to draw a house. But instead of drawing a house, he says, I want you to draw four different versions of a house. But instead of drawing a house, he says, I want you to draw four different versions of a house. And he's teaching them that just as you wouldn't expect an artist
罗恩·伯格的公立学校老师的故事，他就是这种理念的典范。罗恩做了什么来帮助人们以崭新有趣的方式思考他们正在做的事情？罗恩的做法之一是，他会让一年级的小学生画一座房子。但他说，我不要你们画一幅房子，我要你们画出房子的四个不同版本。但他说，我不要你们画一幅房子，我要你们画出房子的四个不同版本。他在教导他们，正如你不会指望一个艺术家
to frame their first draft, that the initial work they do is open to being reinterpreted and can evolve and improve over time. And he sets up a whole challenge network in his classroom, where after you do your first draft, they do what's called a critique session. And all the other students are invited to tell you the things that they think are effective and how you can revise and refine it. Who else would add something? A talk, what would you say?
把他们的第一版草稿装裱起来一样，他们最初的工作是可以被重新解读的，并且随着时间的推移能够不断演变和完善。他在他的课堂上建立了一个完整的质疑网络，在那里，在你完成第一版草稿后，他们会进行所谓的评图环节。所有其他的同学都被邀请来告诉你他们认为哪些地方有效，以及你该如何修改和精炼它。还有谁想补充点什么？塔克，你会说些什么？
About the angle, because not to be mean about the angles, just not exact. Okay, so show me, come on up here, talk. Show me where, what you would ask him to do, slightly differently. And it's not about you, right? It's about the work. Everybody's there to try to help you improve it. And we did.
关于角度，倒不是说对角度要求刻薄，只是说它不够精确。好吧，展示给我看，到前面来，塔克。展示给我看，你会要求他做哪些稍微不同的调整。这与你个人无关，对吧？这是关于作品本身的。每个人都在这里努力帮你把它改进得更好。我们确实做到了。
It is good at it. He is so good. And by the end of going through that exercise, what a lot of students will say is they go home and you've got a first grader who's coloring, and they insist to their parents that they want to do six or seven drafts because they really want to keep rethinking the way that they've drawn somebody's eyes
他真的很擅长这个。他太棒了。通过完成这项练习，许多学生最后会说，他们回到家里，一个正在画画的一年级小孩，会坚持要求他们的父母让他们画六七个草稿，因为他们真的很想不断重新思考他们画别人眼睛的方式，
or the colors that they happen to use in a picture. And what a great way to learn that just because you had a first thought about how to create an idea or how to answer a question, that does not mean that should be your final thought. So it's interesting we've looked at lots of different variations of this idea of the ways in which task conflict sort of spills over into relationship conflict. So very often when we are resistant to change, it's not because of the specific ideas themselves, it's because of the context in which those ideas are located, how the ideas presented to us, what the idea means to us, whether our identities are tied up with the old idea versus the new idea, our general stereotypes, it's all of this larger context that in some ways, you know, holds us almost as if it's in concrete, holds
或是他们在图画中碰巧使用的颜色。这是多么棒的一种学习方式啊，它能让你明白：仅仅因为你对如何创造一个创意或如何回答一个问题有了最初的想法，并不意味着那就该是你的最终想法。所以很有趣的是，我们研究了这种理念的许多不同变体，即任务冲突是如何蔓延为关系冲突的。因此，很多时候，当我们抗拒改变时，并不是因为这些具体创意本身，而是因为这些创意所处的环境、创意呈现给我们的方式、创意对我们的意义、我们的认同感是与旧创意还是新创意绑定在一起、我们的普遍刻板印象——正是所有这些更大的背景，在某种程度上，你知道的，把我们牢牢固定在既有观点上，就像被浇筑在混凝土里一样。
us to our pre-existing views. And one of the things that I see you pointing out repeatedly is that in order to get people out of the cycle where they're interpreting everything through the lens of relationship, conflict and instability, is you actually have to start by emphasizing relationship stability. And in the absence of that, task conflict can quickly become interpreted as relationship conflict. Can you talk to me a moment, Adam, about the very important idea of psychological safety and how psychological safety is connected with getting teams to think more creatively,
我看到你屡次指出的一件事是，为了让人们摆脱那种用“关系冲突和不稳定”的视角来解读一切的循环，你实际上必须首先强调“关系稳定性”。而在缺乏这一前提的情况下，任务冲突很快就会被解读为关系冲突。亚当，你能跟我聊聊心理安全这个非常重要的概念吗？心理安全是如何与促使团队进行更具创造性、
more innovatively and also engage in productive task conflict. Psychological safety is, as Amy Edmondson and Bill Khan and other researchers have defined it, it's the belief that you can take a risk without being punished or penalized. And it's really founded on a culture of trust and respect, where people will say, look,
更具创新性的思考，以及参与建设性的任务冲突联系在一起的？正如艾米·埃德蒙森、比尔·卡恩和其他研究人员所定义的，心理安全是指这样一种信念：你可以承担风险，而不会受到惩罚或惩戒。它其实建立在信任与尊重的文化基础之上，在这种文化中，人们会说，看吧，
if I want to point out a problem, or I have a concern that I might want to raise, or if I think someone needs to rethink a decision they've made, or a judgment that they've landed at, that I can bring that up without having to worry that they're gonna bite my head off. And we know that psychological safety is one of the foundations of building a learning culture
如果我想指出一个问题，或者我有了一个想要提出的担忧，或者如果我认为有人需要重新审视他们已经做出的决定或得出的判断，我可以把这些提出来，而不必担心他们会对我大发雷霆。我们知道，心理安全是构建学习型文化的基础之一，
and making it easy for people to rethink things. Because we've seen this in studies of hospitals, for example, that when teams have psychological safety, they actually admit the errors that they've made. And then everyone else can learn from them and rethink their routines and practices. Whereas if they lack psychological safety, people are motivated to hide their mistakes, and then they repeat them, and no one else ends up rethinking the way that they're operating either. And so I think there's great
它能让人们更容易地重新思考事物。因为我们在医院的研究中看到过这一点，例如，当团队具备心理安全时，他们实际上会承认自己犯过的错误。然后每个人都可以从中汲取教训，并重新审视他们的常规流程和做法。而如果他们缺乏心理安全，人们就会有动机去隐瞒错误，然后不断重复错误，最终也没有人会去重新审视他们的运作方式。所以我认为，
value in creating psychological safety. I'd say it's easier said than done for a lot of people. Amy Edminson is quick to point out that psychological safety is not about being nice, or having low standards. We actually need psychological safety with accountability. We can have high expectations for people, but also give them the freedom and permission to rethink some of even what we might have called best practices. I have to say though when I look out at the culture at him, when I look at sort of the culture of conversation on social media, in our political sphere, you know, on cable TV, I don't see an environment that is rich in psychological safety. I don't see an environment where you're rewarded for being nuanced and for rethinking your
创造心理安全具有巨大的价值。不过我想说，对很多人来说，这往往说起来容易做起来难。艾米·埃德蒙森很快就指出，心理安全并不意味着当老好人，或者降低标准。我们实际上需要的是兼具问责机制的心理安全。我们可以对人们抱有高期望，但同时也给予他们自由和许可，去重新审视哪怕是我们可能称之为“最佳实践”的东西。不过我得说，亚当，当我放眼当下的文化，当我审视社交媒体上、我们的政治圈子里、你知道的，有线电视上的对话文化时，我并没有看到一个充满心理安全的环境。我没有看到一个因表现出细致入微、重新审视
views and admitting when you're wrong. In fact, if anything, the incentives are lined up exactly in the opposite direction. Sadly, I think that's become the norm. I do think though there are some steps we can take to have more thoughtful conversations with the strangers that we love to preach at and prosecute. We can be aware of what psychologists
观点并承认错误而受到奖励的环境。事实上，如果说有什么不同的话，那就是各种激励机制完全朝着相反的方向排列了。可口的是，我认为这已经成了常态。不过我确实认为，我们可以采取一些步骤，与那些我们喜欢向其说教和攻击的陌生人进行更有思想的对话。我们可以意识到心理学家
call a solution aversion. The idea behind solution aversion is that if you propose a way to fix a problem and people don't like your solution, they often reject not only the solution, but also the problem in the first place. So let's say with climate change, for example, if you say, well, we need a whole bunch of companies to reduce their emissions and you're talking to somebody who's a staunch free market conservative. They're not necessarily going to like that idea, and so their motivation then is to deny
所称的“解决方案厌恶”。解决方案厌恶背后的理念是：如果你提出一个解决问题的方案，而人们不喜欢你的方案，他们往往不仅会拒绝这个方案，还会首先否认这个问题的存在。比方说，以气候变化为例，如果你说，我们需要一大批公司减少碳排放，而你正在跟一个坚定的自由市场保守派交谈。他们不一定会喜欢这个想法，因此他们的动机就会变成去否认
the existence of the climate problem in the first place. And I think we should be really cautious about jumping to solutions. We would be better off saying, hey, I'm aware that there are some problems when it comes to climate change, and I would love to hear your ideas about the different possible ways that we could solve them. We shouldn't spend all this time talking about why my solution is right, or why your view that climate change isn't an issue is wrong. Instead, I should say, well, given your views about what we should do on climate policy, how would your proposed solutions work and how would you implement them?
气候问题本身的存在。我认为我们在仓促得出解决方案时应该非常谨慎。更好的做法是说：嘿，我意识到在气候变化方面确实存在一些问题，我很乐意听听你对解决这些问题的各种可能方法的看法。我们不应该把所有时间都花在争论为什么我的方案是正确的，或者为什么你认为气候变化不是个问题的观点是错误的。相反，我应该说：鉴于你对我们在气候政策上应该怎么做的看法，你提出的解决方案会如何运作？你将如何实施它们？
And when you ask those how questions, something really intriguing happens. Psychologists call it the illusion of explanatory depth. And it's the idea that we think we understand complex systems much better than we actually do. And the best way to make us a little bit more intellectually humble, curious, nuanced, more doubting, less dogmatic is to ask us to explain those very systems and their impact. And so if you try to walk me through all of the effects of a greenhouse gas emissions program
当你问出这些“如何”的问题时，一件非常有趣的事情发生了。心理学家称之为“解释深度的错觉”。这个概念指的是，我们自以为对复杂系统的理解远比实际情况要好得多。而让我们变得稍微在智识上更谦逊、更好奇、更细腻、更多疑、更少教条的最佳方法，就是要求我们去解释这些系统本身及其影响。所以，如果你试着带我梳理温室气体减排计划的所有影响，
you quickly realize there are a lot of things you don't know and empirically that that tends to lead you to moderate your views you become less extreme you become more open-minded and we have a more civil dialogue So I want to take a moment and channel Adam Grant in the next question I'm asking Adam Grant. And I want to try and rethink some of the things that we have said in the conversation today. You know, we all know the iPhone was a hit. So we can work backwards and deduce that Steve Jobs was right to listen to his engineers. But there's also some risk in this kind of backward induction. Sometimes it might be possible that inflexibility is actually the right answer. Some of history's greatest leaders have been relatively inflexible.
你很快就会意识到有很多事情是你并不知道的，而从经验来看，这往往会促使你缓和自己的观点，让你变得不再那么极端，变得更加思想开放，从而我们能进行更有文明的对话。所以我想花点时间，在接下来的问题中“化身”亚当·格兰特来向亚当·格兰特提问。我想尝试重新思考我们在今天的对话中所说过的一些话。你知道，我们都知道iPhone很成功。所以我们可以通过逆向推理推断出，史蒂夫·Jobs听取工程师的意见是正确的。但这种逆向归纳也存在一定风险。有时，不灵活可能才是正确的答案。历史上一些最伟大的领袖相对而言都并不那么灵活。
Think about Winston Churchill facing down, you know, Adolf Hitler. Even think of people like Mahatma Gandhi, very singular, focused in terms of what they were doing, very unwilling to reconsider sort of the rightness of their views. Now, clearly, inflexibility is also associated with some of the worst leaders in history, but are there times when, in fact, second guessing can lead to dissension, to dithering, maybe even to defeat? I think those are great examples, and I think you're right.
想想与阿道夫·希特勒正面交锋的温斯顿·丘吉尔。甚至想想圣雄甘地这样的人，在他们所做的事情上非常单一、专注，极不愿重新考虑其观点是否正确。现在很明显，不灵活也与历史上一些最糟糕的领袖联系在一起，但有没有这样的时候，实际上事后诸葛亮或二次猜测会导致内讧、犹豫不决，甚至导致失败？我认为这些都是很好的例子，而且你是对的。
Right, what's the saying that every great truth has an opposite truth? Yeah. So, flexibilities of virtue, so is persistence. And I think that the art, much more than science, is figuring out when to say the course and when to shift gears. I don't think that being open to rethinking
对吧，那句话怎么说来着，每一个伟大的真理都有一个相反的真理？是的。所以，灵活性是一种美德，坚持也是。我认为，与其说这是一门科学，不如说它是一门艺术，需要弄清楚什么时候该坚守阵地，什么时候该转换档位。我不认为对重新思考保持开放
means you always have to change your mind. So if you're Churchill, the goal of beating Hitler, definitely don't want you to rethink that. I do want you though to be open to different strategies, right, because I might find out that their strategy is changed, and so my needs to evolve to. And I think that what that means is we can be pretty steadfast in our principles and our overarching goals
意味着你必须时刻改变主意。所以如果你是丘吉尔，击败希特勒的目标，我绝对不希望你重新考虑这一点。但我确实希望你对不同的策略保持开放，对吧，因为我可能会发现他们的策略变了，所以我的策略也需要随之演变。我认为这意味着，我们在原则和总体目标上可以相当坚定，
and very flexible in finding the right ways to achieve those goals or live those principles. You know, as I was reading your book, Adam, I was thinking about this proverb, I don't remember where I read this, but it said that if you want to walk fast, you should walk alone, but if you want to walk far, you should walk together.
但在寻找实现这些目标或践行这些原则的正确方法时则可以非常灵活。你知道，亚当，当我在读你的书时，我想到了这样一句谚语——我不记得在哪里读到过了——它说，如果你想走得快，就一个人走；但如果你想走得远，就结伴同行。
And I'm wondering if that's possible that second guessing and rethinking might in fact have short-term costs, but long-term benefits. I would say that's an astute observation. I think rethinking... It doesn't have to be slow, but it often slows us down. I worry that we spend too much of our time listening to people who think fast and shallow,
我在想，有没有可能二次猜测和重新思考实际上会带来短期的成本，但有长期的收益？我会说这是一个敏锐的观察。我认为重新思考……它不一定非要很慢，但它通常确实会让我们慢下来。我担心我们花了太多时间去听那些思考肤浅而迅速的人讲话，
and not enough time paying attention to people who think slow and deep. And I might even go further and say, I think we need to become people sometimes who think slow and deep, which is a, you know, I guess a reinforcement of so much of what Danny Coniman has spent his career studying. But I think that there are also ways to accelerate our rethinking. Because it would be very tempting to say, okay, you know, in a lot of situations, what we need to do is we just need to slow down, we need to pause, we need to give ourself a chance to come up with a second opinion and third opinions.
而没有花足够的时间去关注那些思考深沉而缓慢的人。我甚至可以走得更远一点，我认为有时我们需要成为那些思考深沉缓慢的人，这可以说是对丹尼·卡尼曼毕生研究成果的极大呼应。但我认为，也有一些方法可以加速我们的重新思考。因为如果有人说：好吧，你知道，在很多情况下，我们需要做的就是慢下来，我们需要暂停，我们需要给自己一个机会去想出第二意见和第三意见。
And yeah, I think slowing down helps with that. But there's no reason why we can't in the moment say, okay, I'm about to make a decision, I have a clear plan about what I want my career to be or I have an idea about what city I want to live in. And let me take five minutes and just think about all the reasons why that plan might be wrong, not just the reasons it might be right. Let me reach out to somebody in my challenge network and ask them, can you see some holes in my reasoning? Is there any way that I might regret this decision? And that could be a quick reconsideration process.
是的，我认为慢下来有助于做到这一点。但没有任何理由说明我们不能在当下就说：好吧，我马上要作出一个决定，我对自己的职业生涯应该如何发展有一个清晰的计划，或者我对我想在哪个城市生活有一个想法。然后让我花五分钟时间，仅仅去思考这个计划可能是错的所有理由，而不仅仅是它可能是对的理由。让我联系我质疑网络中的某个人并问他们：你能看出我推理中的漏洞吗？我有什么可能会后悔这个决定吗？这可以是一个快速的重新思考过程。
Ironically, it's something we've all been forced to do in the past year by pandemic. So many convictions, I cannot tell you, Shankar, how many leaders told me they would never let their people work remote and are now questioning whether they should even have a physical office. I think it's unfortunate that we only did that rethinking when we were forced to and I think we could take the initiative to do it more deliberately, more proactively, as opposed to waiting until we have no other choice. Adam Grant is the author of Think Again, the power of knowing what you don't know. Adam, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Shocker. This was such a delight.
具有讽刺意味的是，这是过去一年里大流行迫使我们所有人都去做的事情。我简直无法告诉你，尚卡尔，有多少领导者曾告诉我，他们绝不允许员工远程办公，而现在他们正在质疑自己是否还应该保留实体办公室。我认为不幸的是，我们只有在被迫时才会进行这种重新思考，而我认为我们本可以采取主动，更加刻意、更加积极地去做这件事，而不是等到别无选择的时候。亚当·格兰特是《逆向思考：如何知道你不知道的事》一书的作者。亚当，谢谢你今天来到“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢你，尚卡尔。这太令人愉快了。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Midrall Media is our exclusive advertising sales partner. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Laura Correll, Kristen Wong, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Natalie Muala. Natalie heads up business development at our advertising partner, Stitcher Media. She played a crucial role in visualizing how hidden brain media and Stitcher could work together. In recent weeks, Natalie has taken our
“隐藏的大脑”由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。Midrall Media 是我们独家广告销售合作伙伴。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、劳拉·科雷尔、克里斯滕·王、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是“隐藏的大脑”的执行主编。我们本周的无名英雄是娜塔莉·穆阿拉。娜塔莉负责我们的广告合作伙伴 Stitcher Media 的业务拓展。她在构想 Hidden Brain Media 与 Stitcher 如何合作方面发挥了至关重要的作用。最近几周，娜塔莉将我们的
partnership further. She has given me useful leads for philosophers who could be guests on hidden brain. I've always found Natalie to be direct, kind, and helpful. And that is the best kind of collaborator. Thank you Natalie. Many listeners have asked us over the years how they can support our show. We have a way to do that. Please go to hiddenbrain.org and click on the support button. We appreciate your help. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
合作推向了更深层次。她为我提供了有用的线索，找到了可以做客“隐藏的大脑”的哲学家。我一直觉得娜塔莉为人直率、善良、乐于助人。这正是最好的合作伙伴。谢谢你，娜塔莉。多年来，许多听众一直问我们如何才能支持我们的节目。我们有一个方法。请访问 hiddenbrain.org 并点击支持按钮。感谢您的帮助。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。下周见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。